so in today's environment you need to be
flexible you need to listen
um and uh be able to pivot and change
really fast
belief innovation and resourcefulness
will take you everywhere
okay this is going to show my brilliance
heaven you ready for the deep
wisdom filled your encounters
today's episode of model monsters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles i've done over
3
800 split tests which have led to
results like taking this 5 year old
video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail it blew
up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for free
at tubebuddy.com evan and now on to the
show
let's learn from the master dean
graziosi
and there he is what's up evan we tried
this one other time and it didn't go so
well so
oh man how many times did i try i was
stressing out so much on that day
trying to bring you in it's like just
kept crashing anyway
we're making it it's happening welcome
man good to see you man how you doing
i'm good how's how's arizona everything
i see in the news looks crazy
and we just i just stay in here i'm in
my house like i feel like you gotta
like we have to hunker down yeah
arizona's a little crazy but you know
it's only crazy in little pockets you
know it's great that arizona looks like
the party city of the world all they
show is b-roll of like
people at the clubs and partying and i
think that's what did it but
uh we all we're all just adapting to the
new norm so what's up man it's good to
see you
i i see you all over the place i see you
hustling i see your impact in lives
doing amazing stuff on youtube
um you know dude you are
i know i want to share whatever works
for you know you're following my
following today
but i want to share dude your book built
to serve
you are built to serve there's a
difference when
you know this is i've been an
entrepreneur for entrepreneur for over
30 years i've been in the self-education
industry for 24.
can't even seem doesn't even seem
possible but there's a lot of people
that
when you kind of meet your heroes or you
meet the people behind the book
a habits book a built to serve book a
time management it's like you beat you
meet the guy with the time management
book and he's late getting on stage and
stressed out of his mind in the green
room
like there's no congruency is what i
wanted to say and before we chat today i
just want to honor you and give you
congruency this
what you wrote in this book is really
who you are man you
are built to serve you reach out to my
team all the time and
want to help with youtube and tell us
what we're doing wrong and it's not
you're not doing it because of
finances you're not doing it because
you're trying to get an edge you're
doing it just because
this is who you are man so i love seeing
you out there i love seeing you grow i
love seeing the impact you're making
cool man appreciate it i'm still working
on accepting compliments so
um i'll just say thank you then i'm
going to keep doing it through this
entire thing to make you feel
uncomfortable
oh great classic dean all right cool
well you know i also in that story um
you know you've been really helpful in
getting that book out i remember when i
came to puerto rico and uh
was trying to get feedback on pre-launch
you and brendan richard took time
backstage
while you're doing your big event people
paid all this money to come there and
you took time
over lunch for 40 minutes to do a deep
dive
on my strategy um and just super
grateful that you guys did that and
you hooked me up with your warehouse and
you know a whole bunch of things that
dean's the big reason why the book is
has uh
just a little piece man just what's up
everybody i see the highs so how can we
deliver some value today how do we help
out besides
um i do got to plug this like if you
didn't check out
uh evans built to serve you should check
it out um the truth is
i'm not all the way done i freaking love
it my biggest problem is
every book i read evan i listen i i have
such a hard time reading i still have
dyslexia
it still doesn't stick so it's taking me
longer but when i actually read a book
it sticks so i highly recommend it and
uh
it's just you it's like it's it's having
a 200 page conversation with you which
is
which is always cool cool man appreciate
it well we also i also have an audiobook
version i read it myself
so there's always oh dude please send
that to me
dude why are you torturing me with this
i mean i love the words but don't
torture make me read i would have had
this baby done
weeks ago so send me that uh okay
we'll get you hooked up okay so i
thought it'd be cool actually i just
finished reading yours too
i i'm a slow reader audio is even worse
for me
but i did that's the first book i ever
did an audio on in my life so
really yeah i just finished it i love it
there's a lot of stories in here i mean
i've seen so much of your videos and
so much your content there's a lot of
stories in here that i didn't know like
man that's
that's some cool stuff i like it so
underdog advantage guys go check it out
um i thought i thought maybe we'd do
some q a with the audience too and
let's do it get some takes here so you
guys you got a question from your dean
pop it in here
what's one positive belief that you have
that you believe others do not yet
believe
a positive belief um this might seem too
generic but maybe it's because i'm 51
because i've been an entrepreneur since
15 i've never worked for anybody in my
entire life
and that's not because i came for money
it's the complete opposite
but in high school i used to cut
firewood actually in eighth grade i sold
bubble gum
fifth uh 10th and 11th grade i started a
firewood business i used to just i
bought an old chainsaw i chopped trees
you know deliver cords of wood then i
started buying wrecked cars and
so i never worked for anybody in my life
so just know that transition but i've
been around long enough to know
that one of the greatest things i'm
going to give two answers to that
one is i promise you your beliefs
if you're watching me right now if you
say i want to go to another level this
covet thing it's
it's been chaotic and i recognized i
want to shift my life i don't want to go
back to my old me i don't want to go
back to that old job i don't want to go
back to
you know worry letting someone else run
my life or whatever it is that you
recognize
beliefs are the most powerful thing like
if someone said you could go back and
talk to your 17 year old self
i would teach on beliefs so whoever
posted that um exceed your potential
great question because at this phase if
you told me this in my 20s i'm like
yeah you've been living in california
too long right like it just wouldn't
have sunk in that the only thing
standing between you
and where you want to go is the belief
you have on why you can or can't get
there
and i know you've heard that a million
times it's like it's personal
development 101 but man sometimes it
doesn't stick to your ribs
until you hear it from someone i'm
telling you the only thing that got me
through was my beliefs
and the times i stumbled and stressed
and failed it was my beliefs
it had nothing to do with the government
or the president or the economy or the
people around me or if my family
supported me or not or if i had money or
not
it had to do with my beliefs and then
being
innovative and being resourceful so
those three things
belief innovation resourcefulness will
take you everywhere
but the question was because i didn't
even answer is what is the one belief
you have
that you believe others don't have yet
if you haven't been through hell and
back and found that
your success lives on the other side of
your
worst fears your biggest obstacles the
belief is that
i truly believe that anything i truly do
i believe you know i didn't i didn't
have a great relationship and i'll take
responsibility for it in the past and i
got a divorce years ago
but i found a new belief that there
could be real connection real love
real soul mate and i started believing
that every day and i attracted the love
of my life
together three years every day we fall
more in love
we have a new baby like it's amazing
because i
shifted my beliefs on that i believed
that someday i'd be partners with tony
robbins the guy who inspired me 25 years
ago when i bought his course off an
infomercial
tony and i talk seven times a day we
have three companies we started now
i'm busy every day of my life because of
that belief that someday that was going
to happen and i just wish
someone would have shaken me earlier in
my life and say
shift those beliefs you know get rid of
it you know even even all the stuff
going on in the world evan i believe if
we all shift our beliefs just ten
percent
we could solve all the problems but
anyway i i
i went way long on one little question
oh no i love it
and for anybody watching uh it's easy to
see dean
in this environment and he's so
comfortable in front of the camera and
making all these videos and ads and
everything else but
uh i got to hang with him kind of behind
the scenes
and spend days with him and his wife and
he lives it he lives it right
still holding hands still making time
still maybe not coming out
at night with everybody else because
he's got to go not gotta go chooses to
go
be you know with his wife um and so
that's a
that's a super huge inspiration she was
like the only one who's backstage
when dean's on stage he's backstage all
the other speakers i see they're just by
themselves but there's dean
you know with his wife and they're
always together and so it's um
dean's living he's living it from
someone's house behind the scenes he's
living in
um well i was to that question i would
just say i think everybody's got michael
jordan level talent at something like
you're the greatest in the world that's
something
i just have to believe in that and chase
it down how did you start changing that
belief
dean for you like that relationship
provided that i would i was going to go
get tony robbins like
a lot of people have these big goals
ambitions for themselves but then
they have this moment of inspiration
where they
believe it and then they wake up the
next day and they don't believe it
anymore like how do you keep that
consistent
so so i would love to say there's a lot
of answers that came to my head one time
like
obsessing on a compelling future don't
listen to the inner villain like all
those things come to my head at once
like i want to spit out
it's like i feel like uh like i want to
send say 10 things at once
but i would say that one i play a little
i play little tricks on myself like i i
definitely
hack my own emotions and my own thoughts
if you don't think i
still okay this is what i do every day a
month i still feel like an imposter some
days you know that's the new thing i'm
gonna i have an impostor syndrome
it's a new term but i always felt scared
to death and felt i'm not good enough
i'm not smart enough why
how did i get in this room right why
these people are way smarter than me who
invited me
right i still feel that way right
so know that those emotions will always
be there
but i think if i look back evan
i think is i do little things like
looking back at the end of my life
at the end of your life are you going to
say i'm glad that i played small and i
didn't go for that dream because man if
i went and i failed that would have been
horrible
no at the end of your life you're like
what the hell did i waste this for
like i i was young i was vibrant i lived
in this i lived on earth
i was like i had endless possibilities
and i let
fear or i let complacency or i let
procrastination
stop me screw that like i will do that
to make myself disturb
evan you know me i still play as if i'm
broke and i'm 10 points down
i do i hustle like i don't i hustle like
i can't make my mortgage payment
it's because i found a way to like i
know the impact i want to make i know
the success i want to achieve i feel
like
if we're not climbing or sliding like
tony says this elegantly like we're
really put on this earth for growth and
contribution
right it's like and last year we fed six
million
we provided six million meals we we i
donated a half a million dollars to help
kids in slavery like each 1500 bucks rob
saves a child like i didn't say that to
like brag
my whole point is find things two things
look at the side if you don't take
action like don't just say oh if i do
this i can have freedom if i do this i
can have more money if i do this i can
do better things for my family my
children
you gotta look at the other side too
evan you gotta look at what if you don't
like some of you are gonna be more
motivated by
if you don't than if you do because all
i know is if i don't do this
i could go back to where i'm not in
control of my time where i can't coach
literally
or i can't coach softball or i can't
spend extra time with my wife or i can't
be a good leader why i can't have new
kids
you know have new babies that i can be
home with like take that away from me
take away my life so i'll fight like i'm
broke i'll fight like an underdog
yeah anyway that's a long answer to a
short question
cool okay next one reject mediocre i
like the name says what has been your
biggest challenge on social media
biggest challenge on social media um
staying consistent
you know there's some days you're busy
as heck so listen social media has a a
million different variables
um you know like youtube this is my dear
friend
evan knows youtube better than anyone on
the planet and still we can't find the
time to focus on it it's the reason it's
not going so sometimes it's just focus
so but just know this when you focus on
something
things that get your attention grow and
x and grow exponentially right if you
think about if you're in good shape
it means you focus on what you eat and
you go to the gym simple as that you
read books you
you hear somebody give you a tip on
working out you do it because you're in
the moment
right if you want to uh grow
your social media if you want to make
more impact there's
you learn from evan and people like that
it's just it's all about getting your
focus
and attention um i i don't think there's
a big challenge except for time
and like you know instagram is something
i put let's just put it this way
because instagram is easier for me every
day i can just hit the button and go
live and deliver value
in the last two years we went from like
30 000 followers we just passed a
million
right because it's getting my time
attention focus i'm consistent i go in
there every day
on the opposite side youtube i just
haven't been completely focused and it's
doing great
but it's not growing like this but if i
put that same focus on youtube
my youtube channel would grow so that's
my biggest challenge is just finding the
time and
partnering with tony and writing books
and being a new dad and a new husband
and five thousand other things
and that's why the the one answer to
that has nothing to do with social media
is
truly truly find the things in your life
that matter
and do more of it and find things that
don't matter like at the end of your
life
like why did i waste my time and do less
of it as simple as that when people ask
me how i do it all i know what i mean
i know what's important to me and i
spend my time in those important places
well i was speaking to your team last
week about youtube again so
gave him some tips
come on dean we got this i was reading
expert uh traffic secrets by our friend
russell brunson
and he mentioned you in the book and how
he came and looked at all your ads
and how the only difference he saw was
that you were making
two to three ads a day and he was doing
like an ad a week or something
and just you never know which i was
gonna hit and
one of the things that that i admire
about dean is that he gets
he's very productive but he's also very
intentional with how he's spending his
time
so when everybody's taking a break in
puerto rico
there's dean recording an ad like
walking down the beach making another ad
he's like i got
five minutes to do something i'm gonna
use that five minutes instead of wasting
that five minutes um
and so i looked at that like man i i
need to i i feel pretty productive as a
human but i'd like
i got inspired by that as well say hey
if you can find time to make ads
i can find time to make more videos as
well um
but i agree consistency right i mean it
took me it took me
five years to get the 7 000 subscribers
and then another five years to get the
two million
and i didn't take it seriously and all
this stuff at the beginning but um
in the in the daily videos coming up
especially in a platform like youtube
instagram is a lot more
uh of the moment youtube has a lot more
of my videos
four years ago are still getting me
views so
if you have a lifelong kind of ambition
drive brand
um it's picking the platform that makes
the most sense for you too
ooh i like this one here how do i
improve my confidence
um okay great question confidence is so
important
one of the things we have to protect if
you want more out of life is our
confidence
and what i would say is how do you
improve your confidence is to identify
to identify the things that rob your
confidence
okay this is going to show my brilliance
heaven you ready for a deep
wisdom filled here decide what takes
away your confidence
and do less of it look at that
brilliance here on a thursday no there
are things that
subconsciously or consciously take your
confidence with i just want to know
something let me ask you it sounds
silly but when is the last time if
you're on right now
when's the last time you watched the
news
and got done and your confidence went up
ever in the history of the world when's
the last time
you tortured yourself by talking to your
friend or your family member
that tells you you're a dreamer that you
should get real that you
that's not the way the economy is not in
this world there's too many people
online you can never be in this business
you're not going to grow your following
when's the last time you had a
conversation with them and you left and
you had more confidence
right when is the last time you worked
on one of your weaknesses
right there's something you suck at but
you force yourself to work on it
because you think you should be better
sorry calling it out here on a thursday
if you're if you suck at something
forget it
go get great it's something you're
already good at and pay someone to do
that
so what i'm saying is there's things
like watching the news talking to
negative people
working on your weaknesses inner
self-talk
bad monologue going on in here that will
kill your confidence and when your
confidence is low you don't
you don't ask for the deal you don't
close the deal you don't ask somebody a
partner
don't ask for the money it like has
anything ever in your life been good
when you have lack of confidence
never you never get it done but then you
have those rare moments when you're on
fire you're in a state it's like i'm
getting this done
no matter what i'll rip the doors off
this building i'm getting it
so what do you do more of who do you
watch online who do you listen to
online what what thoughts do you tell
yourself that put you in a state
of bulletproof confidence and what
things do you do
that take it away i'm not trying to
oversimplify it figure out what takes
your confidence away here's my
brilliance
and do less of it figure out what builds
your confidence up
here's the brilliance of the second note
do more of it
what's one recent thing you had to cut
out
recent thing i had to cut out past 12
months
past 12 months i'm always chopping stuff
out of my life uh
saying no to speaking events around the
world
and even and when i said no some people
were doubling the price they thought it
was a negotiation tactic
like oh you won't come for that how
about we give you this but um
you know i i did just get married i have
a 13 year old 11 year old
and a three month old so i want to be
here for that three month old but also i
want to be here for my 13 year old she's
you know she's 13. she's gonna be 14 in
a few months you know it's like it's
going to go like
this and she's been going off to college
or doing her own thing and it's like
it's my firstborn she's my heart so i
just want to be here more
but also when i'm here more because what
happens i travel you know what it's like
you fly to dubai
it's like it takes forever to get there
you gotta be there for three days
and you come back when i come back i'm
overloaded with work
so then i gotta hustle for five days 20
hour days to get caught up and
manage 13 different businesses and then
i don't get to spend so it's like the
five days away and then the five days of
catch up
so i just said it's i'm gonna spend i'm
gonna i'm just nuking that
and what i found is in most cases when
you say
no to one thing even if it's hard two
two better things to open up i love it i
think confidence too it comes from doing
difficult things
like scary difficult to hard is not an
acceptable reason for you not to go
listen you know what i think something
really if you hear anything today hear
this
i think most people are waiting for
confidence to come to take the actions
they need to get the results they want
right when confidence doesn't come
without the
the c word before it that's courage
courage is taking
uncomfortable imperfect action when
you're scared to death
confidence that courage has nothing to
do with um
an absence of fear courage is the fear
is there and you're freaking doing it
anyway
so you must be courageous in so many
ways if you ever want to find the
confidence you want to uh
you know to do what you want to do in
your life yeah i think you have no fears
you hate your life
you're just photocopying the same day
over and over and over again
yeah evan do you know anybody that's uh
a trust fund
child that is happy joyful and uh living
a perfect life
no i'm not trying to be rude if you are
i hope you're one of the good ones but
everyone i meet is all hosed up
they're trying to find purpose in their
life they went through rehab twice i
sounds like i'm being stereotypical but
it just i've been watching this for 20
years
and i observe it now because i'm a dad
and i don't want my kids to go down that
direction i tell my kids all the time
you're not getting trust funds i'll
leave you opportunity
but if i don't feel it's opportunities
there's going to be some happy charities
around the world right
i want to hand off opportunity i don't
want to [ __ ] my kids because you take
away that drive that
fear the overcoming the obstacles then
what is life
then what is life right become a
socialite oh my god
i love it let's get one more one more uh
what is the one skill entrepreneurs need
to have in today's business environment
flexibility flexibility
i deal with a lot of companies i'm
dealing with one right now um
and it's like the whole who who moved my
cheese right
it's like things were working great
until covet hit
and people get certainty when they had
success right getting out of
success they call it a success trap was
harder than a failure trap
when things that you were doing worked
and they were successful it's hard to
shift
so if you need to be a an entrepreneur
it needs to be light on his feet like
you want to build no matter how big your
company gets
you want to build a speed boat not the
titanic
because if it's the titanic and it's
slow moving when the ice that you know
they say about the titanic they saw the
iceberg for like a half a mile
and they couldn't get out of the way
right it's like that's what happens with
big businesses if you're not innovative
and you're not flexible it's like you
see the change coming but it's so big
we just gotta hope the world changed
like the book who moved my cheese like
let's just wait here
until the world opens up it's like no we
we need to get out of this room and go
find different cheese
so in today's environment you need to be
flexible you need to listen
um and be able to pivot and change
really fast
where do you sit on five and ten year
goals you know i have some pretty big
goals i just wanna keep growing as a
human
i wanna impact more lives i wanna do the
things that light me up
i wanna my my goals are like um
like who i want to become i just want to
keep becoming a more congruent
um growing human that that provides
value to the world
that my kids can look at me at every bit
they can look at my phone my life
my texts my messaging hear my
conversations when i don't think
anybody's listening and go
that's just my dad that's who he is he's
not this guy on camera
he's not this guy when he writes his
books he's not this guy in front of his
employees and then this guy to my mom
it's just that's my dad and so i would
bet to say i just want to keep growing
to be just congruent that's just who he
is
i love it so why i asked that was
because people you just said you have to
be flexible
and a lot of people have they set five
or ten year goals for themselves and
then
and then covet hits and everybody's got
a plan until you get punched in the face
right
yeah but what i love about yours is more
like the person i want to be not a
specific i have to hit
x yeah because listen if i become the
person i want to be the byproduct will
be all the
time freedom and money you could imagine
right so i'd rather set
and i i give credit where credit's due
when i was 46 years old
um 47 maybe tony robbins
you know i was in florida at his house
and he looked at me and he said
and i've heard this before but the way
he asked me changed my life and said
who are you going to become in your 50s
and i was like three years away from
being 50.
and like oh that's british no no i don't
get what you want to
accomplish who do you want to become and
just the way he asked me it shifted me
man i was like
i don't know who did i want to become in
my 50s and i started making lists of the
man i wanted to be the leader i wanted
to be the husband i wanted to be the
father i wanted to be
like and it changes everything and that
that really crafts your next 10 years it
really crafts
your all your success because would you
take a million dollars a year to
compromise your ethics
i know who you are evan would you
compromise your ethics for 100 million a
year
right so it's like once you become this
person i think all the other things
um uh follow along i love it dude that's
that's gonna stick with me for a bit i
like it
i can see i can tell what you were
thinking so that's good yeah yeah it's
good
uh cool well dude it's crazy how time
flies when you're having fun for for
people who are watching this on my
youtube that we're gonna post it to
where do you want them to go next to
dive into the world of dean graciosi
besides picking up
underdog advantage where are they going
uh you can just
go to you should go to my youtube
channel right i should say that my
youtube channel i have a podcast that's
doing great right now we're in the top
hundred
uh podcasts right now i i feel so
blessed that it's here it's called the
dean graziosi show
obviously on instagram and if you want
to grab the underdog advantage go to
deansbook.com
appreciate you man thank you for the
time glad so much as well
thanks brother see ya if you want to see
the last time i sat down face to face
with dean graciosi and ask him how
he markets effectively check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there what would your typical message be
to somebody if they went through that
wagon wheel exercise
and they were hitting it on all
cylinders would you tell that person i'd
probably say the full